バンダイさんはパンにマギアの担当させがておりますお世話になっております
餡にはギア前回の動画で作らせていただいたんですけど
魅力的な商品なと思って遊ばせていただいたり頭が一つ
モード申したいことがございます
うまくカスタムっていきませんあれはセンスがないんです
twitter で見かけるんですよアニマギアのカスタマーの画像とかクオリティが
やばいんですよ
どうすればあんなに上手に上げマギアでカスタムできるのか
私できないであれば直接開発者様のアニマギアのカスタマイズを見て学んでもっと上手
になればいいなと思っております
カスタムの日本作っ
てきたいただけたということでべきの報道で二軍カスタマイズを公式ホームページ
たくさんアップしていたんですけど今回の塊に一番時間をかけましたけど一番嬉しく
なるよざいます入って言うけどちょっとアニメディアの説明まずさせてくださいアート
組み立てる加藤クリームパスタ
この3による新時代がんぐっ
いうことでございますこちらにあるのがに負けの第5弾ということで何か今回特徴が
あるんですか
まあ一段から4段まで今発売していく
いろんな動物をモチーフにした兄曲げを作っていたんですけどもう
カスタマイズをもっと楽しめるいう家ようになっています4
例えばこの越冬デュアライズカップする正深むざしっていうやつなんですけど今こう
やって見ると
腕とか星とか背中とか
今回サンミンジョイントは至る所について
雪とかをいろんなところに実は月れるなんでへともっともっと皆さんにカスタマイズを
楽しんでもらいたいなというところで
8こういった8カスタマイズジョイントっていうのを
田身に着けているキャラクターが出てきました素晴らしい
伸ばす
here
ていたりするのでえっ多く新しいかっこいい感じになってるかなと
そして第3が目をギアス
このですねはい
フリック姿まあ
ペニックス
でかっこいいですへーどんなに半値めっちゃかっこよくないですか
羽がちょっと重なっているような造形にしているので
と
金の奥行き感というかたしそういうのを表現できるようか憎悪するするような活動にし
ます
雑魚としてくれますねございますこちら taiga on
全卵のと彼をストライカーすバイライオンが出たんで
ライバル的存在として降雨以来パティますしてつなごうギア
ですはい件中の逆んモチーフとした
アニマ試合です
いや第5弾すごいですね今回もそうですねいい感じに仕上がってるかと思います
プレ等を使ってどのようなものを作れるのかを見てください
[音楽]
まず一帯にがはいじゃあになります
おおこれは
私を創造しておりました六田池がかっこいいからなんとなく羽を生えさせ様みたいな
そうですね感じは私もちょっと待っておりました
このボディがすごいですね寝起き安が武蔵合体したとってうーんインしてをやりたかっ
たのでいろんなところに骨をギアスのオレンジが入っているという
e 0ボディのこの一部分だけがいるかっていうのすごく
さらに実は背中に弓矢になって
s 5位
ブービー嫌悪やてぃかっこよ笑みを構えているはポーズをちゃんとトレーディオって
いうところもフラグですよてょしか使ってないんですよええ
ます
次は3対3タイツを買ってバランスよく作ったものを創造者になったを徐々に上げて
いく
はいこちらにあります
[音楽]
これすごいすごいすごい
やはりですよほんとな事態は義理がたいしてるんです子とらーが量からサイドから合体
して真ん中にクワガタがいる
でめっちゃかっこいいじゃないですかあなたの苦労とティに入る苦労と後足にもある
黒瀬戦う最強の格闘の最多をつくっていう
ブーバー悲哀を石田ぜひしてくださいっちゃいまー
しっ
ええええ
[音楽]
ガー
根本的なスケールジャンが違いますよあっはぁこれは10体を使ったらずっとで使って
なきゃ嫌になります
絶対を使っても大きいバランスの良い人形を作ろうっていうの頭に思い描いて胴体作っ
て
うで作って腕作って足つって最後に合体させるという
こいつだってこんな僕の頭ではたのこの子ずローででを作った n
脳の思考からならないですからですね人ギニア健夫
何で作ろうっていう最初に考えた時にこの五段のパーツを見て
てになるパーツがこの小次郎の子の足の大きい部分しかないなぁっていうのを最初に正
爪気付いたというかそうだなっていうのを持って孤児を売りにしよう
これまで出来るんですね作るコツというかちょっと学ばせていただきましたはい私を
頑張って作ってみたいと思います
あんなん見せられた後の俺の気持ちを考えた事あるかい
あのクオリティは絶対作れないと思うんですけどもそれでもかなりいろんな情報という
かアニメやのカスタムのなんとなくの方法はちょっと学べた気がするんで作ってみたい
と思います
エグザ
[音楽]
ん
と2型かですもう赤いフェニックスをイメージして作ろうとして上半身だけ作ってみた
んですけどもな感じですね
顔だ絶対フェニックスの顔を使うと思っていーくんかを使ってるんですけどやっぱこの
羽かんだしていきたいですねー
今こんな感じですか反射はまったくできてないです引き続き頑張ります
ああああああ
そういうイメージができたのに辿り着けないもどかしたらすごい
あったきたっちゃさあ発想の勝利だよね
何だぞのってきたぞ
[音楽]
と夕食で2時間ぐらいかかりました前作ったやつよりかは相当カッコイイのが出来てた
なぁと思って作らせていただきました
早速開発者の人読んでみましょうぺーぺーちゃんヌードルください
いっ
はい
大
[音楽]
そうきましたああ
いっそ起きました動い単色で攻めさせてもらっすごい
えっ
相当すごいですね掘るのがこのパターン難しいんですよむずか昔
完全な人形ってわりと頭の中でイメージしやすいんですけどもんまいとこういう
スタイルでつくる本当に僕でも難しいんですよ
人形じゃないですか結構アニマギやっぱりこの世辞がピンッとしてるのが多いんです
けどなんか曲線
の猫背で足がないのでてるタイプの虎僕も会前のミリーのドラゴンってかっこいいです
学校ですね司会のが悪いをちょっとってが宇宙にそうな所ですね
かつ異論をちょっと統一したくて尿器安するのオレンジと
後はこちらの赤を入れつつパハン州として後ろに
目指し
憲法そうですねちょっとあの時と解しさをなぜたくて後ろのここ
そうでそうでソックス5位そこパシンできた時にあっきたパワー負けな名前だねはい
スペースボール型のコラボニックっドラゴンたんびゃく80式ですよ
by よしおおっちょっこ負けてるけどあー
おったん半ばぐらいすごいすポンドに考えられてるんじゃなくて気持ちちょっと負けた
からそんな
で全姉あるって言うぐらいすごいです本当にすごい
さあ全然に褒めていただいて満足です web
対0で今回ですねバンダイさんの兄はギアの開発担当者の方と今ギアの
この日本を見せていただいたりそれを見てはに曲げをカスタムさせていただきました
楽しかったりされるありましたがとーございますステージでアニマギやなんですけども
スーパーのお菓子売り場に売っていたり自分の作りたいものを組み合わせ次第で何でも
作れちゃうくらいの素晴らしい食玩でございます
アニメディアの第5弾
発売日10月の19日から案にマギアのカスタムコンテストが始まるみたいでござい
ます
どうやらのマスタークラスをトナーの方たち部門とジュニアクラスの子どもたちブロー
もあるみたいなんですけどもすごいですね
そうですねやっぱり創造次第でこれだけ面白いものが作れるようになりますのでこうお
待ちしております
bar タクシー肇社長も応募しておりますのでぜひ皆さんも参加してみてください
そして今回服とかスター
の商品をですね商品のホームページに載せておりますのでそちらもぜひ概要欄から
チェックしてみてください
面積は本当にありがとうございますございました次はでもっとずっと小川しておきます
のでお待ち取りましょうありがとうございましたはありがとうございました
[音楽]
padi